one time dude you know what I want to
leave you with this and this is how you
can tell nah I'm not gonna leave you
with this because I guess I must want to
talk about after this but one time and
this is how you know life rips this is a
life rip story and this is a [ __ ]
it's gonna be all good story one time
when I was coming up through high school
look at these hands
look these [ __ ] hands you know what
these hands are and what I've always
thought these hands are sexy hands I've
always thought I've had sexy hands ever
since I was in high school I thought I
had very masculine capable piano
fingered sexy hands that's what I've
always thought okay now I got to be a
sophomore or a junior in high school and
I wondered why no girls ever said I had
sexy hands because it never happened and
then my senior year my friend Brendon
goody said has any girl ever told you
you had sexy hands and I was like here
it goes Brendan's gonna tell me finally
I have sexy hands now of course is not
from the opposite sex but who cares I'll
take what I can get and I said actually
no smirked and i laughed i Chuck a
little bit because I thought I knew what
was coming and Brandon said it's crazy
twice last week two different girls said
I had sexy hands and I I had never been
sadder in my life
because I thought Brendan was gonna tell
me I had sexy hands or he heard through
a grapevine that Joanna said I had sexy
hands or whatever the [ __ ] but in fact
no it was the twisting of the knife
Brandon who by the way God is my witness
doesn't have sexy hands and that's me
taking me out of this that's not even me
being jealous that's me standing away
from both of us looking at both of us
thinking that if there was somebody that
didn't have sexy hands between the two
of them it would be Brandon okay
innocent bystander Chris but that's what
he said to me and I said oh wow that's
crazy
pissed pissed inside my heart I went
home you know you do you do what you do
you live life years days turned into
months months turned into years years
turn into decades quite literally and
then your boy turns 35
one day
oh I blink and I'm 35 and I'm on a date
with a girl not really because I don't
really do that and I don't like to waste
a lot of time and money getting to know
a girl not because I'm cheap and not
because my time is expensive but because
maybe you [ __ ] suck girl honestly
maybe we suck together maybe we are not
compatible but getting to know each
other and getting to know if we are
compatible over a dinner that lasts one
hour and 30 minutes and is going to cost
your boy a hundred and twenty dollars
that's not my bag but I was hanging out
with a girl and I think it was that
coffee because you know me and she said
you know what you have I didn't know
what was coming it had been a long time
since I talked to Brandon good he hadn't
even thought about the hands thing and I
said what and she said you have really
sexy hands you know what I mean I'm in
that zone where I'm just falling and I'm
remembering I mean it's like that it's
like the [ __ ] 3/4 the way through the
movie where you realize all the guy has
a history he has a past that's what it
is and it's directed really badly by
some [ __ ] second time director that
had a fee that did kind of well and then
the second movie didn't do as well
because of these kinds of [ __ ]
sequences the guys falling in it's extra
ultraviolet colors and I'm remembering
what Brandon good he said and now I'm
not laughing out loud like I did when I
was with it Brenda goody I'm keeping it
to myself because I'm older now and I'm
wiser now and I'm knowing stuff doesn't
really mean anything unless you let it
and I go huh really
and she says yeah and I said that's
funny she says why and I said because I
always thought that I had sexy hands and
nobody ever said that until now and she
said oh yeah no totally they're really
uh they're really masculine and I went
Wow huh and guess what
you boys 39 now and I've heard that at
least six or seven times from different
girls so I guess my point is
don't get so depressed when you're in
high school or something because
something happens because maybe it'll
turn out to be [ __ ] awesome later now
that's a story that means a lot to me
and it might not mean a lot to you and
it could be oh this guy's got no
problems he's living in the first world
okay fine
but problems are micro to a macro you
know maybe you're out there and I really
mean this in high school and you're
alone you're lonely and you're crying
every day and you feel bad about
yourself and you feel about bad about
being alone about your parents about
your friends school's hard going through
puberty is hard whatever the [ __ ] it is
maybe you feel like you have a small
dick or big feet or bad acne but I'm
telling you right now there's always
that moment later on were you it's not
that you realize oh [ __ ] I do have sexy
hands it's that you realize it doesn't
matter if I do or not
so take that with you okay
and just remember life rips I have more
to talk about but I feel like we should
end on that hand story